performance
okay oh no it's not gonna be very good
so as you can see your pattern is scored uh based on the number 10 so out of 10
is your what is your one as you can see it's split up into two
parts we have our accuracy and our presentation
of this site so we'll start off with the accuracy first
so uh your accuracy it's actually scored from
a four so from the number four uh you're actually marked during your
presentation of your pattern and then with that one
any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake
you get a minus of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake
you get minus 0.3 so i'll i'll just let you guys know about the
difference between the two so with a minor mistake it's a very very
small thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder
height it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a
tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1
a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the
pattern but you forget and you say you do a rich
hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake so
with the minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example
there's uh 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes
in the 20 minutes sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being uh it
needs to be absolutely perfect to get uh
to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20
steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes
so what would that be so we'll leave that there
on this side and we'll come back and we'll just come with the squat here
at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left
but you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so
obviously we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes
so uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the
presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six
uh this six is actually split up into three parts
so we have one two three here so with this one
uh for a score of two is your power and speed
your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also
scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with
this one whether it's your blocks your kicks
your strikes your punches anything you are that you do
you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well
so it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch
but it has to be both strong and fast to get
high in that in that category the next part is your rhythm
so the rhythm uh when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern
it's not just really fast all the way through it's not
through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well so you do
need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also
scored out of two the last bit is your expression of
energy so what is expression of energy so that's
basically uh how loud you shout so how much
intensity you have during your pattern as well
so say you're doing your pattern really well
it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great
but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of
tell the judges can kind of tell oh you're not really
confident are you you're a little bit nervous so that's why
we need to kind of get the fruit on on as well so i'm just coming on to this side
so with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little
bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll actually
uh your average so where where the judges actually mark you from
it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so
say you did uh you did all right you did an average compared to everyone else
your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so
if you're less than average in the judge's eyes
you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a
one or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get
a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual uh
category you need to obviously get as high as you can
Well, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your current speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing.
It might be just a 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So, your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So, with this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So, with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So, let's see.
So, for presentation, we had 1.7, 1, 2, 3.
So, you had a 3.7.
So, let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So, with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is, with the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel.
And each judge, obviously, is very subjective.
So, from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So, that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So, say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So, if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So, this would be your accuracy score.
So, with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.7.
So, we add these numbers after the judges.
So, finish scoring.
So, you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So, I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here.
So, if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon.
Generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So, if you get a number between...
4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So, anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say...
Because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7...
is actually considered almost world-class.
So, if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back
because you did an amazing job.
So, we just went through our pom-zay scoring.
So, just remember, accuracy is a 4.0.
Presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judged during your pattern.
Presentation is after.
And then we get two scores that we add up.
And we get that number.
So, with this one...
Obviously, say I was judge number one.
I would give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did.
And maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5. something.
Another judge on the other side, they scored a little bit higher.
So, we'd get three numbers and then we'd average that as well.
So, I hope this helped you guys.
So, make sure you enjoy your pom-zay competitions.
And anytime...
Make sure...
Obviously, you record down your number.
Okay.
Perfect.
Okay, so this is the same performance.
You're going to be watching it without pausing.
So, minor errors, major errors, real-time.
And then once you're done, power and speed, coordination, rhythm, and expression of NR3D.
Cool.
Okay.
So, just...
Yeah.
Please.
Yes.
Okay.
My stance is not together.
I don't know.
I don't know...
Okay.
Yeah.
No. This is so bad. Let's go with 9. All the moves are right. Um, okay. I don't think there's
anything major because all the moves are right, but it's not good. Okay. Power speed. Intensity.